Scranton Pennsylvania Allison is calling
hey Allison welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave hi Rachel
hey Allison Holker we hope okay I have a
question I'm having a very hard time
budgeting and my husband wants nothing
to do with it he doesn't want to help he
just was like you handle the money
how do many suggestions yeah I mean this
is the biggest hang-up that I talked to
so many couples about and again I think
it's this natural tendency that
opposites attract so he's probably
naturally more of a free spirit
you're probably naturally better at the
money so people just take those roles to
an extreme and say you do this and I
don't have to worry about it but I love
what my friend Chris Hogan says he says
it's never I in marriage it's we we
should be French a little bit more we we
and so coming together and just telling
him from your heart of like hey I don't
want to do this alone and you shouldn't
have to do this alone Alison like having
all this responsibility on you isn't
fair to you you guys are in this as a
team and hopefully having a conversation
like that and showing him hey this is
important to me this is what I value
this is what I want us to do not just
for you but for the sake of your
marriage and be able to come together
and the hard line is if past that
conversation he still doesn't want to I
think there's probably some of you know
other issues that you guys are gonna
have to deal with but but forced and
foremost having a sit-down not just a
blow-by conversation of hey I want you
to do this and it's like I don't really
want to and you're like okay but sitting
out on having a very very intentional
conversation with your expectations and
what you want Alison I'm guessing
Rachel's probably right that you are
more than nerd he's more the free spirit
like I'm more than err at my house
actually I'm the more the police spirit
and he's more than earth but he just was
like you pay the bill um I'll deal with
it later
and he doesn't want to spend any money
at all for like clothing anything it's
all saving yeah and we have two kids so
that's kind of hard yeah that's kind of
ridiculous yeah so um here's what I
would do is two things
um one is I don't mind executing paying
the bills I do mind being the only
grown-up in the house that makes
decisions and so the two of us need to
sit down together and develop a plan
I'll even develop a plan and you look at
it with me and we both agree to it but
I'm not going to make be the only one
here that makes decisions you're going
to help me with
I need my man to man up and help me make
the decisions not that you're not able
to make decisions as a woman that's not
the point but I I would if it was
reversed if isn't you know a husband
calling by his wife I'd say I need my
woman to step up beside me here and
woman up and you know carry the
decision-making because when you agree
on your spending on paper then you can
go write the bills out okay but that
it's the decision-making in the
agreement that Rachel's talking about
this so vital and so important when you
agree on your spending you're agreeing
on your life
Jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is and when you don't agree on
your spending you're not agreeing on
your goals but when you agree on your
spending you're agreeing on your goals
or going on your fears
you're agreeing on you know where we're
eating Thanksgiving dinner is going to
come up which parents house you know
because it's all in the budget we got to
travel further for one than the other
you know it's all in the budget and it
all comes up and once a month he needs
to go over it with you and be in
agreement with it a so that he sticks to
it B so you're not carrying all the
weight of the adult decision-making in
your household by yourself
Rachel was exactly right and the way she
answered that to you okay yes thank you
very much hey thanks for the call hey
you guys Rachel Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you